كثيره هي المناطق التي نكبت بسبب الزلزال
الكارثه الانسانيه بسبب هذه الازمه هي
الاساس لكن ترافقها ضخامه التاثيرات اعاده
البناء في المناطق المنكوبه ستستغرق وقتا
وعلى الاقل عقد من الزمن لا تزال تعاني من
زلزال 2010 وتحاول اعاده الاعمار دمر
زلزال فيها 60% من النظام الصحي اعيد بناء
بعض المستشفيات لكنها حتى الان لا تعمل
بكامل طاقتها التشغيليه بسبب النقص في
المواد والموظفين الخوف في تركيا من مصير
مشابه فاينلز وصفت جهود اعاده الاعمار
التي ستبدا بها تركيا بانها الاكبر منذ
تاسيس الجمهوريه عام 1923 فالتكلفه
الاوليه تقدر بمئه مليار دولار
تكلفه كبيره لان الخسائر الاقتصاديه كانت
ضخمه وتصل الى 84 مليار دولار بحسب اتحاد
الشركات والاعمال التركي بنك جيبي مورنينج
قدرات التكلفه الاوليه للخسائر بانها
تعادل
2.5% من الناتج المحلي الاجمالي لتركيا
المناطق التي ضربها الزلزال تحتاج الى 16
مليار دولار لتشييد المباني المدمره فقط
فيها كل هذه الخسائر ستؤثر بالتالي على
عجز الموازنه والمرجح ان يرتفع من 3.5%
الى
5.4% لكن الصوره ليست قاتمه بالمطلق في
اعاده الاعمار ما قد يثير الدهشه في احيان
كثيره هو السرعه الكبيره التي تتعافى بها
البلدان من الحاله حاله الدمار بسبب
الكوارث وهكذا يرى الامر الفيلسوف
الاقتصادي البريطاني جون ستورت مل طبعا
يختلف حسب حجم الكارثه والاقتصاد المحلي
والقاعده السكانيه وبالطبع المنطقه
الجغرافيه المتاثره دراسه نشرتها الامم
المتحده في وقت سابق اكدت ان الكوارث
الطبيعيه هي فرصه لاعاده البناء بشكل افضل
وتحقيق قفزه تنمويه من خلال بنيه تحتيه
متطوره لم تكن لتوجد في غياب الكارثه
خصوصا مع وجود اموال المساعدات في تركيا
وكما تحدثنا في حلقه الامس كان لديها عدد
كبير من المباني التي شيدت بشكل مخالف
خمسه وسبعون الف مبنى في مناطق الزلزال
فقط وهنا ترى الامم المتحده ان الامر
الايجابي الان هو تشييد مباني بشكل صحيح
وقانوني واكثر امتثالا لقوانين البناء
ضربت المنظمه مثالا ابي زلزاله ستوان عام
2008 في الصين كان بقوه 7.8 درجات حصيله
ضحاياه نحو
وذلك بسبب ضعف الامتثال لقوانين البناء
وبعدها تغيرت معايير السلامه في المقاطعه
الصينيه لكن دراسه اخرى للبنك الدولي
وصندوق النقد الدولي حذرت من امرا خطر
خلال عمليه اعاده الاعمار بدافع الحزن
والاسى قد يتم الاندفاع للعمليه دون وجود
مؤسسات مخصصه لذلك اندونيسيا نجحت في
تفادي هذا الامر بانشاء مؤسسه يقودها
خبراء ومختصين
كشفت اتحاد الشركات والاعمال في تركيا ان
تكلفه الضرر التي قد يتكبدها الاقتصاد
التركي بسبب الزلزال ربما تتجاوز 84 مليار
دولار وتمثل الولايات التي ضربها الزلزال
ما يقارب عشره في المئه من الناتج المحلي
الاجمالي للبلاد بينما قال البنك الاوروبي
لاعاده الاعمار والتنميه ان الزلازل قد
تتسبب في خساره ما يصل الى واحد في المئه
من الناتج المحلي الاجمالي للبلاد ويقدر
اقتصاديون ان زلزال سيخفض النمو الاقتصادي
بما يصل الى نقطتين مئويتين حيث توقعت
الحكومه في وقت سابق ان يشهد العام الجاري
نموا بنسبه 5.5%